retro rack and tour here guys another
day another job posting I promise you
we're not going to be doing one of these
every time Avalanche post a new job but
this one is a pretty big deal because I
personally can't think of any reason
that you would hire a game director
unless you're working on a brand new
game that being said I have reason to
believe that it is not Hogwarts Legacy 2
but something else entirely good news
bad news I don't know let's dive in here
okay so just to start here I've seen
some people who are curious about how
I'm finding this information this is all
public information this isn't some
Secret website you guys can go here
right now it's careers.
wb.com it's just the WB careers site
there's a section there for Avalanche
software and so you can see anytime jobs
are posted hey you might find a job that
you might be interested in go ahead and
apply for it if you'd like to work on
Hogwarts Legacy or at least with the
Hogwarts Legacy team because once again
the wording here is ever so slightly
just a little bit different who knows
maybe the marketing folks are talking to
the HR folks like hey guys why don't we
just keep tweaking this wording because
we know they're going to parse through
every single little piece every word
that we say to try to figure out what's
going on and truth be told that's
exactly what we're about to do one of
the things that stands out right away
about this one is the fact that it is a
remote position if you recall in the
last job posting we talked about and for
the majority of jobs with Avalanche
software they are located there in Salt
Lake City Utah where they are
headquartered seems this one is going to
involve more remote work and it is a
full-time position all right here's
where it gets fun I was talking to my
buddy expecto go earlier and he was
saying that it feels like preh Hogwarts
Legacy all over again man and that is
exactly how it feels it is incredibly
exciting because it says here join the
team behind the Blockbuster open world
action RPG Hogwarts Legacy as we create
what's next so remember last time they
talked about that language of the
Hogwarts Legacy team they don't quite
say that in exactly the same way here
but they do still have that wording
right here about creating what's next
reading on Avalanche software seeks a
game director join the team who created
Hogwarts Legacy a new open world action
RPG set in The Wizarding World this
phrase right here should describe
hogwart's Legacy and I believe that's
what they meant but the way that they
threw in new right here I mean I guess
technically if you say this year it is
still new but just the way that reached
join the team who created Hogwarts
Legacy a new open world action RPG set
in the wiing world I could almost see
how someone would read that and think oh
they're creating a new open world action
RPG also set in The Wizarding World I
don't think that's what they're saying
here though I I do believe that this is
describing hogwart's Legacy here but
wait there's more they will work closely
with the franchise creative director
franchise art director and a bunch of
other people as well as external Studio
Partners to create a product design that
is in harmony wait for it wait for it
wait for it with the company's
objectives for the larger franchise
ecosystem and development team
capabilities BL blah okay lots of things
here about franchise about larger
franchise ecosystem all right so now we
have to try and figure out what they
mean by larger franchise right here I
mean the most obvious possibili you
would think oh they're just talking
about the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter as a whole right the entire
franchise that is definitely a
possibility maybe even the likely
possibility however I also think we have
to consider the fact that they could
actually be referring to hogwart's
Legacy as a franchise which we know
according to an article from earlier
this year by variety where they spoke
with WB Games president David hey Dad
variety says Warner Brother sees
Hogwarts Legacy as a
longterm franchise dude and then you
have this job posting talking about the
larger franch ecosystem which dude now
we're left to try and figure out what
franchise ecosystem are they talking
about here exactly so if you're one of
those people who hates speculation let's
cover the facts first fact number one
Avalanche software is hiring a game
director you do not hire a game director
unless you're working on a new game that
much we can be certain of they are
working on a new game and if we want to
drill down even further they meaning the
Hogwarts Legacy team is working on a new
game switching over over now to my
speculation hat check out the retrak
andour shop if you'd like to get one of
these for yourself all you have to do is
visit retrak tour.com scroll down until
you see merch click on that right there
and then if you go all the way to the
bottom of the next page you'll see two
different styles of hats that we have so
again speculation hat in place what I
hope this doesn't mean I hope it doesn't
mean that Allen 2 has left or is leaving
Avalanche software if you guys didn't
know or if you didn't remember Allen 2
was the game director for Hogwarts
Legacy and having met allent 2 in person
I think he did an absolutely spectac
acular job directing this game and if
they do choose to make a Hogwarts Legacy
2 it is my hope that Allen would be
leading that up now at the same time we
also have the WB Discovery president
David zav saying that they want to have
these franchises and make them live
service which yeah I know it's been a
bit of a Hot Topic here so taking all of
that into account my personal hope is
that this is actually for a game
director to lead a brand new game under
Avalanche software within the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter it's exactly what
I and so many other fans like my buddy
James expecto go would like to see in
fact he and I just recently sat down and
had a very lengthy chat about the future
of Hogwarts Legacy and the future of
Wizarding World video games you can
check that out here on the left side of
your screen now as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon